i am going to build a backyard movie
theater
in your house if that's okay
she's going to build a backyard movie
theater
as soon as i heard the bonnaroo family
story i couldn't wait to meet them
[Music]
i'm andy and i'm thomas and we live in
magnolia texas
and we have eight amazing children hi
i'm sadie
i'm david i'm debbie i'm daphne
my name is thomas this is joey my name
is cara
hi i'm grayson hey robin how old are you
i have always had a heart for foster and
adoption i always knew that's something
i wanted to do
so we we thought about it for a while
and then in 2016
we started looking into getting licensed
for foster and adoption
since cove had started we haven't been
able to go out to the movies or get out
of the house as much as we wanted to
we've had movie nights at home and just
crowded on the couch
with all the blankets and the pillows
and the bearded dragon
and it's been a really great bonding
time one thing i like about movie nights
is that it always has popcorn to go with
it
when i heard how much they love their
movie nights i teamed up with walmart
plus to give them the ultimate backyard
movie theater and even though i was on
vocal rest
we got straight to work all right guys
she locked her voice
a little bit so bear with us it says
sorry it's so nice to meet you
oh my gosh it's so nice to meet you
oh all yep all of that's walmart
obviously there's the things from your
line
more styles of the blanket
we have more styles and wanted to add
those to it
they're like comforters you know yeah
okay yeah there's three more styles
let's get them all
okay just for a variety yes okay
oh of those loungers the chase lounges
how many of those are we getting
and how many of like the you know the
double chases and this other chase
i requested three of the the double
sheds and then i believe two
of the the yard loungers more of the
yeah the other three
all the blankets you have all saturdays
love the pillow
it comes in other colors as well we
should get multiple colors of it there's
like a pink color
the the green and then we can just do a
mix and match for
the chases and okay if you look where
um on the bottom left hand side of that
page it has that inspiration with the
wood
surround do you see on the bottom left
hand side
nope the surfer yeah do you see how that
surround is built around the screen
i want to build that around the
projector screen and then attach the
movie letters
the marquee letters amazing
my name is kelly and drew has sent me
here to create the most ultimate movie
night for the bonnara family
we have spent so much time picking up
every single last
detail and we are so excited about this
and we can't wait for you to see it
ready to do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
y'all ready to see your ultimate
backyard
movie experience yeah
[Applause]
we wanted to give the family a backyard
where they could create memories for
years to come so we decided to
break their space into three areas a
lounge area
a dining area and then of course the
backyard movie theater
when choosing all of these items comfort
and durability
were key i wanted the furniture and
decor not only to look elevated but also
withstand eight
kids running around i'm so proud of how
this backyard movie night came together
this family is so deserving
and i feel so lucky to have met them hi
i'm gabby what's your favorite food
um spending so much time at home these
days
including the bonnaroo family i hope
this backyard
continues to be a space where they can
relax and have
fun at the end of a long day